president's national security adviser
jake sullivan joins us from the white
house to tell us more about this strike
good morning jake i hope all is well
let's jump right into it we just heard
that al-swahiri was downtown kabul with
taliban assistance what does this say
about the relationship between the
taliban and al qaeda
well first we do believe that senior
members of the haqqani network which is
associated with the taliban knew that
zawahiri was in kabul there may have
been other members who didn't and we are
communicating directly with the taliban
about their obligations not to allow al
qaeda
to use afghanistan as a basis for
plotting but let me say this
what it also says is that president
biden's pledged to the american people
that even after pulling american men and
women out of active combat in
afghanistan we would able be able to
take out terrorists in afghanistan he
made good on that pledge this weekend he
showed that we can actually keep america
safe take terrorists off the battlefield
and not have thousands of american men
and women fighting and dying in
afghanistan for 20 years of war that is
a significant success for the
president's strategy and americans can
feel safer today now that the leader of
al-qaeda ayman al-zawahiri is off the
battlefield
jake it's vlad uh so you just confirmed
that the taliban was aware that azuahiri
was in kabul so if the taliban continues
to harbor terrorists what is the united
states prepared to do what is president
biden prepared to do well we are
communicating as i said directly with
the taliban about their obligations to
live up to their commitments and also
our capacity to hold them accountable
for not living up to their commitments
because we're not obviously just going
to take their word for it we proved that
this weekend by taking out al-zawahiri
and we're prepared to take further
action to ensure that afghanistan can
never again be used as a basis for
attacking americans that may have
sounded like just words a year ago but
today
it's words backed up by swift and
decisive action if there is someone
plotting in afghanistan against the
united states or if there is an al-qaida
leader trying to inspire attacks against
america and americans as zawahiri was
doing we will find them and we will take
them out and we just did that and the
president has shown the wisdom strength
and success of his policy
in this action that he ordered over the
weekend
national security adviser jake sullivan
thank you